of the dynamic grass Workshop
so two brief announcements one brief
announcement
um
we will be hosting a open problem
session at 4 pm after the last talk
today
this will be like an informal talk where
um anyone can go up to the Whiteboard
and present their favorite open problems
and hopefully I sparked some
collaboration among the workshop
so
uh
University of Maryland
and Google research and he'll be talking
about parallel batch Dynamic graph
representations
a largeman is an assistant professor in
the
Department room computer science at
University of Maryland he obtained his
PhD from Carnegie Mellon University
where he was advised by Guy Blalock and
was then a postdoc at MIT with Julian
shun
his research revolves around designing
high performance parallel Dynamic and
streaming process graph processing
algorithms and systems with the focus on
both practical and theoretical
efficiency
interesting
um so hey everyone so Jason my name is
lakshman
um I'm with UMD in Google research so
today I want to tell you about some of
the work we've been doing on building
practical graph representations and it's
kind of a continuation of the talk that
Helen gave um yesterday
so I hope this is going to be
interactive so if you have questions
I'd like to love to hear your questions
and talk instead of getting through all
the slides
um we're all here for a workshop on
Dynamic graph algorithms hopefully I
don't need to convince you that graphs
are interesting and useful to study
um they basically give us a way of
representing connections and
relationships between objects
one thing I want to say is a lot of the
graphs we think about in practice are
natural so-called natural graphs maybe
they come from friendships or you know
connections between roads but there are
also other kinds of graphs which are
important in practice where the notion
of you know being connected is if the
two objects are similar enough and this
might be from some machine learning
model for example you might run a
network embed your points in space and
then connect two objects if they're
within Epsilon distance Epsilon of each
other and then semantic similarity can
produces some sort of graph that you
then want to process in cluster
it's a lot of important problems with
graphs and some of the more practical
ones that people I think care about at
Google and other companies are for
example clustering very large data sets
doing things like unsupervised learning
using graphs for example produced by
these Notions of similarity finding
similar images or removing duplicates
using graphs to solve a pro approximate
nearest neighbor search in very high
dimensions and then doing things like
spam abuse and fraud detection so they
have a lot of you know real world impact
and people are making billions of
dollars
um and you know maybe if you go to
Industry you can make billions of
dollars if you have a good idea
so graphs are very big
um and one graph I'm going to focus on
throughout the talk and that I've
focused on in my work is this web data
Commons hyperlink graph this is a graph
with 3.5 billion vertices and 128
billion directed edges it's a hyperlink
graph which means the edges are drawn
from web pages and you know a web page
with a hyperlinked another web page
creates a directed Edge between them and
if you store these this graph using a
standard format like compress bar screw
it's basically the adjacency list format
where all the adjacency lists are stored
back continuously it requires about a
terabyte of memory to store when you're
storing both in edges and the out edges
for every vertex
and this is the largest publicly
available graph that we have today
although people like Kuba are working on
building bigger ones so in a sometime in
the future we might see even larger
graphs but I should say you know
although this is the biggest publicly
available graph we have there are much
larger ones that are available at
companies so people have graphs with
trillions of edges already available to
us and this blood is kind of showing the
rate of growth of graph data so that
y-axis is showing the number of vertices
and edges in these graphs and the x-axis
is showing the year that the graph was
collected and you see this this is in
log scale so you see this exponential
growth and increase of graph size so we
need algorithms all the things that we
care about sublinear algorithms parallel
algorithms we basically need to we can't
get away with running sequential
algorithms and we should try to avoid
looking at the whole input if we can
afford to although that's not really the
focus of my talk so the main point here
is that you need to use parallelism in
order to actually process these graphs
in a reasonable amount of time if you
ran a sequential algorithm it would take
hours to days and there's no hope of
actually getting your answer back in a
reasonable amount of time
so there's been a lot of work motivated
by this problem on graph systems okay
the graph people cared about graph
processing a lot in the 2010s and
there's been hundreds of papers that
have been written and this is just a
small sample of them you could probably
go on for pages and what kind of
questions were people studying what are
the questions that we can ask
well we can ask well how is the graph
represented so the questions that we
care about kind of span algorithms
representations and programming language
type of questions so we can ask
ourselves well how is the graph actually
represented and what format is it stored
in and whether you know what what is the
the hardware that the graph is stored on
is it stored in memory is it stored in
external memory
and similarly we can ask well how do
users write programs to analyze these
graphs is it something that requires a
PhD in parallel Computing to do or is it
something that you could ask an
undergrad to when they could actually
write a correct program
there's again in terms of Hardware
there's a question of whether the system
uses multiple machines for example
distributed memory or it just uses a
single shared memory machine with
multiple cores inside of it I'm going to
focus in this talk on the single machine
setting although there's interesting
questions here as well
and finally for from the perspective of
building these systems if you implement
an algorithm using the system and your
algorithm emits good theoretical
guarantees is the system actually going
to achieve or realize these bounds or
are there some reasons that the system
might be inefficient
so
I'm going to focus on this talk on
shared memory graph processing systems
and I just want to quickly convince you
that these systems are feasible and just
by renting some compute off the cloud we
can already process a graph at the scale
of the web data Commons hyperlink graph
and again that was a graph with about 4
billion vertices and you know like 100
billion edges
um so we actually when during my PhD we
processed this graph on This Server here
it's a server that guy bought in I think
2014 or so for about the price of a
Nissan Leaf and in terms of depreciation
right this is much more affordable now
you buy this used you could buy this for
about three thousand dollars but a used
leaf is much more expensive
so it's you know sharing memory
Computing is becoming commoditized and
we should this is something that we
should just assume and you should be
designing algorithms for this setting
that uses multiple cores and uses lots
of memory
so again remember it takes about a
terabyte of memory and so you can just
go to Amazon and rent a machine like
this for about ten dollars an hour or
you could you know buy one off eBay for
about three thousand dollars and you
could already fit that look this largest
publicly available graph in the main
memory of your machine and still have
plenty of room for algorithm specific
data
so I I in the first part of this talk I
want to tell you about some of our prior
work on static graph processing and
summarize what we know about static
graph processing in in terms of being
able to process these graphs quickly so
during my PhD we're motivated by looking
at all that prior work on graph
processing systems and if you look at it
and look at the problems they study they
study the same set of like five problems
they study breadth research page rank
between a centrality some sort of
shortest path algorithm usually Bellman
Ford and maybe one other which is
basically some variant of BFS
and so the question we were asking
ourselves well there's a whole many
other problems you teach in our
undergraduate algorithms class many
other graph problems and so how do you
solve those problems in practice on very
large graphs can you solve them or is it
hard and how complicated are the
resulting algorithms
so this led to our work on The
graph-based Benchmark Suite or gbbs
and this is a paper we published in 2018
and it's a graph processing system in
Benchmark Suite that specifies input
output specifications for a collection
of 20 problems and this is since grown
to a list of about 30 problems and what
we showed is that you can take very
simple textbook algorithms from the
literature on Parallel algorithms you
look back in from the 1980s all the
algorithm people developed for the pram
there's actually a lot of very practical
ideas in those algorithms and so if you
carefully sift through the literature
and just Implement carefully Implement
algorithms from the PRM literature you
can get very fast and scalable
algorithms that are practical and scale
to the largest publicly available graphs
so our goal was to understand whether
you can actually solve all these
problems in a reasonable amount of time
on that web data Commons hyperlink graph
and The Code by the way is publicly
available here and I also want to
mention so I in my work with Google
we're actually using this graph
processing system as well as some other
shared memory Computing tools that came
out of guy's lab from this time
we use it for graph clustering primarily
yeah
happy to talk off
so the focus of that work was well we
want to actually understand the
theoretically efficient parallel
algorithms are useful so theoretical
efficiency we have to be working in this
model we worked in the work death model
and you could think of this as kind of
like the pram where time translates to
work sorry the processor time product
translates to work and time is depth so
if you're familiar with pram that's how
you map but the work death model is much
more intuitive the work you kind of
think about your program as a
computational tag and the work is just
the number of nodes in your tag and the
depth is the longest directed path in
this tag or the critical path of the tag
and using a scheduler like a work
stealing scheduler you can schedule the
Stag even if it's unfolding dynamically
in running time the actual number of
steps equal to the work of the number of
operations divided by the number of
processors plus Big O of in-depth
we live in a world still where the
number of processors is fairly low so we
need to worry about this this is the
term that dominates so we care about
designing algorithms that have low work
I mean we don't really care about flog
factors in the depth for example or even
polynomial factors algorithms with and
Epsilon depth might be fine in practice
so our goal is to design and use work
efficient parallel algorithms which have
work that asymptotically matches that of
the best sequential algorithm for the
problem and this is the gold standard
ideally we could design algorithms that
are work efficient and have poly
logarithmic depth in NC
are there any questions so far
so I said we were implementing
theoretically efficient algorithms these
are the running like the work and death
balance of our algorithms so I'm showing
this for the 20 problems that we studied
in in the paper that we published and
what I want to draw your attention to is
the fact that for most of the problems
the work is linear in the input size
there's a couple of problems that have
an extra diameter factor in the work and
so those are only really going to be
practical on graphs that have low or
bounded diameter but real world graphs
mostly have logarithmic diameter
and some are slightly super linear but
not not but only by log factors and in
most cases the the depth is also poly
logarithmic although again in some cases
we're picking up a diameter factor in
the depth
and again I want to emphasize these are
not algorithms that we came up with we
the point of our work was just to
validate that the theory that was
developed in the 1980s in the pure
answer pyram literature is actually very
practical
um and so what do I mean how fast are
these algorithms
well that on the web data Commons
hyperlink graph that I showed you we can
solve all these problems in under three
minutes so you you have to basically
load your graph in memory and using a
commodity multi-core machine a machine
with 72 cores and a terabyte of dram you
can solve all of these problems in under
three minutes
so
um you should be thinking to yourself
like for most static problems
there should be a good parallel
algorithm that basically achieves this
kind of
um time you know it's you don't have to
wait hours to do this you don't have to
use any fancy systems just by using
efficient shared memory algorithms you
should be able to get you know running
time with order of a few minutes to
solve these static problems
so how do we do this well we we build on
prior work in graph processing systems
so we in particular we build a high
level graph processing interface in the
lineage of ligra and this is what Helen
was also talking about there's a edge
map vertex map interface that you can
use to describe these graph algorithms
in addition to that we have a data
structure for bucketing which is useful
for expressing parallel set cover and
certain other
graph problems that need to basically
store information about vertices in
buckets
um the way this kind of works is we map
operations on graphs and vertices down
to a graph representation layer and this
is basically the representation layer is
agnostic of how the underlying graph is
stored so there's you know different
types of representations and you can
Implement your algorithm in terms of
higher level Primitives that don't
really care how the graph is stored and
finally these representations are mapped
down to a library for efficient
parallelism called parley lib and partly
lib both can compile down to other
parallel runtimes like Silk openmp or
tdb as well as use a a like an internal
scheduler that's that we are calling the
Homegrown scheduler
and in terms of how you program these
algorithms they're done using very
simple kind of Primitives you would
learn in a programming language just
class for example things like mapping
reducing filtering or packing and
intersecting vertex sets
um as well as some kind of whole graph
operations
so the thing that's going to be relevant
in the second part of this talk is this
compressed representations in gbbs and
here we what we're doing is basically
taking the adjacency lists
um of the graph and compressing them by
using Delta encoding so you can think
about taking the neighbor lists of a
Vertex and sorting that neighbor list so
you're sorting the neighbor IDs and then
you're all you do is store the
differences between consecutive IDs and
you could compress these differences
which are typically very small using
something called a bytecode and so
typically the number of bytes you need
to represent a neighbor ID is about 1.7
bytes per Edge on average so instead of
requiring about a terabyte of memory to
store the graph in the static format you
can store the graph in about three
between 300 to 400 gigabytes of memory
and so this is for the symmetric this is
the symmetric symmetized version of the
graph and this is for the directed
version of the graph
so just to complete this part of the
graph the talk on static graph
algorithms
um we compared our static graph
algorithms to some existing results on
the same problems but in the distributed
setting so the question is well how much
better is it to use shared memory
Computing instead of what people were
typically doing to solve these large
graph problems which is using either
external memory or distributed memory
systems and so there was a for this
problem of computing the k-core of a
graph the k-core is the maximal
connected subgraph where all vertices in
the subgraph have degree at least K and
the way you compute this object is by
doing some kind of peeling algorithm in
the distributed setting there was a
prior result which solved this problem
approximately so they basically compute
a two approximation for the coordinates
value of a Vertex the cornice value
being the largest k-core that that
vertex is a part of
um they do they compute an approximate
value because if you could actually peel
the graph you require a huge number of
like distributed synchronization rounds
so that's why they're continuing a two
approximation and it takes them about
350 seconds using about 8 000 processors
16 terabytes of memory and of course
they're getting an approximate result
using very expensive supercomputers
which none of us can afford on the other
hand using our commodity shared memory
multi-core we can solve this problem
exactly in about three minutes using 72
cores a terabyte of main memory and you
know get an exact result
so in pretty much every Dimension using
shared memory Computing
um is a strict Improvement so if your
problems is you know if you can solve
your problem in main memory you should
be doing this
um please
how much has that improved
so there's a more recent so if you look
at undirected connectivity
um there's a more recent result from
about two years ago where we're
basically matching the running time of
the distributed computing uh the
distributed like super computer setup
but they're still using like a hundred
times more cores than us this results
2018 right so he's asking how much have
things improved since this point in time
but also
yeah because it's 2018 right
oh
okay yes these numbers are also from
um the result in 2018 so I imagine if
you ran this on if we ran this on like
the latest and greatest processors this
would be even faster right
so I was wondering like why do people
use them
well if you want to actually implement
the pram there's like a strict synchrony
assumption in the P Ram so you assume
that your processor processors are
running in lockstep and that was a
pretty impractical assumption it's very
hard to actually realize that on a real
Hardware
um so the work I mean these parallel
models are all sort of equivalent up to
logarithmic factors in the depth that's
what guy was saying in his talk
yesterday so
I I would say what what we're doing is
showing that the ideas from the 80s kind
of transcend the PRM model there are
some ideas which are very specific so
when they started like working on
getting like log star in-depth
algorithms
um those are maybe not going to be
portable but some of the more like high
level ideas about how to paralyze
problems are portable
sorry while we're on that
kind of questions
a while back everyone was talking about
like uh you know mapreduce you know
having a hundred thousand process
so which are not a multi-core so that is
not not being used these days by Google
say
well I we should talk afterwards
um yeah
please
so what Lakshmi is talking about is
about like graphs of hundreds of
billions of edges but we have wraps of
tens of trillions of edges so so there's
still there's still scale
or whatever it is now
excellent so there's definitely I'm not
saying that shared memory Computing is
this one size fits all it's going to
solve all your problems for you it's for
a particular range
I guess um like what I would say is you
think about the distribution of problem
sizes what the kind of problems we have
and maybe at academic Labs let's say
you're a computational biologist your
problem almost surely will fit in shared
memory machine so it's not until you're
like at that NIH and you're running on a
database of like a million or you know
10 million genomes that you need to
worry about distributed infrastructure
and maybe people are pulling the trigger
and using distributed computing too
quickly like you shouldn't be using
mapreduce unless you really have a
problem with that scale
okay so some summary from this what we
know about the static setting
we have efficient implementations of a
wide range of Basics and fundamental
static problems these are parallel
algorithms that can run on graphs with
about 100 billion edges in a few minutes
and you can download these codes and try
them on your graphs
and these graphs basically these
implementations use compressed
representations using difference
encoding that and the representations
actually have good guarantees so if you
implement a theoretically efficient
algorithm the run the system is actually
going to realize those bounce and you
can store these real world graphs in
very little space right about 1.5 bytes
per Edge and so some questions still
remain in the static setting I'm not
saying wrong with solved uh one question
I'm very interested in is well how do
you actually scale to about a trillion
edges cost effectively of course you can
just buy RAM and pack or you know solve
a problem with ram but this seems like a
bad idea because now I had to spend like
200 000 to buy enough RAM for a graph
with a few trillion edges so maybe it's
time to revive the parallel external
memory model and see what what kind of
algorithms those are and how they
perform in practice
and also yeah for people here
um they're very interesting more
difficult problems for example flows
matchings solving exact and approximate
distances when our graphs have larger
diameter that become interesting
practice
quick good question so I remember on the
slide that you showed that your
symmetric compression was smaller yep uh
is a is it easy to explain why because
you're storing twice as many no so we're
not storing the in edges anymore the in
edges are the outages once you symmetry
so you can't access from both the sides
I mean if I want to be able to say I
want all the Neighbors in a symmetric
graph no so in once you've symmetrized
the graph you basically taken all the
edges and made them bi-directional so
you can you don't need to worry about
your out edges and in edges they're just
one set of edges
right but the number of Weights have
doubled from but yes when you when you
symmetrize you don't really double the
number of edges actually a lot of the
edges are already bi-directional so
that's why the symmetric size is lower
but still how does it make it lower I
can imagine it being compatible on the
Epsilon more why was it significantly
better it's because you're representing
like more edges and maybe maybe you can
talk about this offline okay yeah but
basically a lot of the edges are already
bi-directional and so when you
symmetrize you're not actually doubling
that number of edges
um we should chat offline
so in the next part of this talk I want
to tell you about some of the work we've
been doing on Dynamic graph
representations
so of course real world graphs are
Dynamic and all of the static graph
processing systems that we looked at
they really model the graph as static
and so there's very few systems that can
actually model the graph as Dynamic and
modeling it is actually Dynamic matters
for many kind of important applications
for example maybe you're at a bank and
you want to detect fraud in real time
maybe fraud corresponds to cliques or
cycles of some sort and there's other a
lot of other applications we're actually
getting real-time guarantees
um and real-time information about your
data makes a huge difference maybe for
pandemic detection
um and other types of systems right
maybe for indexing and retrieving data
like in an a n system
um so we need these kind of systems but
there's very limited work on graph
processing systems that actually can
support Dynamic algorithms and
especially ones that admit good
theoretical guarantees
so we're all here and we all work on
Dynamic graph algorithms so you should
be wondering well isn't there a lot of
work on Dynamic graph algorithms
and yeah there there is but I would say
that the model
um and you know guys already kind of
talked about bash Dynamic algorithms but
the model
made sense back in the 80s when you know
the rate of change was kind of
reasonable so maybe updating your our
data structure one element at a time
um sort of made sense but it becomes a
poor fit especially in the modern era
when you're getting millions of updates
per second so maybe millions of users
simultaneously making calls emails
Etc
and of course there's been some
interesting work on actually
parallelizing single updates so taking a
single update and showing that we can
run that update in NC so there's some
interesting work on parallelizing for
example frederickson's algorithm but the
updates are still sort of happening one
at a time right and in order to actually
get more parallelism you should be
batching in some way and this might
explain why you know dynamic graph
algorithms haven't really caught on in
practice as much as they probably should
have because we're not taking advantage
of the fact that you don't need like to
know the answer after every single
update you you typically only need like
you know 10 millisecond or a minute
level latency and so that means you can
batch together updates and process them
all at once
so we should really be considering
um and I invite you to consider this in
your in your work the batch Dynamic
model where we now allow batches of
updates as well as batches of queries
and guys said this already in stock so I
won't really repeat myself but the the
at a high at the highest level you get
two advantages from batching batching
dizzy more parallelism for example I can
take my data structure here apply this
entire batch of updates and get the new
data structure and then make a batch of
queries in parallel on the new copy of
the data structure as well as it can
potentially reduce the work that we pay
per update because of some kind of
sharing in the um in the update
algorithm so this is showing the fact
that guy mentioned yesterday namely that
you know if you're doing kind of K
queries you you have basically this
entire top part of the tree that's
shared and they only pay individually
for the bottom part these like log nrk
levels
we have some prior work on bash Dynamic
algorithms that's been happening over
the past couple years I think Julian and
pointcoin will talk about
um some of these Works
um the main thing I want to say here is
that the algorithms are work efficient
okay so if you basically take the
sequential time and you multiply by K
that's exactly the work you get for a
batch of K updates but irrespective of
what K is you get poly logarithmic depth
so you get an algorithm even in the case
for example for dynamic connectivity
where the work is amortized log squared
and per update the worst case depth is
log cubed n with high probability
the only work that's practical so far
that we've actually implemented is
um or batch parallel Euler batch Dynamic
Euler tour trees and this work was also
implemented so we have a actually
practical coordinates estimation
algorithm but the other two are not
implemented and I think implementing
these algorithms and seeing if they're
practical is very uh exciting Direction
so I want to step back from talking
about algorithms and look at
representations because if you're doing
bash Dynamic algorithms you probably
need to represent your graph so this is
sort of the simplest thing that you
should solve first to actually represent
the graph in low space and get fast
update times and then probably the
representation should enter interconnect
nicely with the algorithm and we'll talk
about that at the end
so we have a graph
um we have objects in the graph maybe
these are new stories these are
embeddings of new stories or something
and this the setting I'm going to
motivate today is the graph streaming
setting so we have simultaneously
arriving
um and trying to access this graph in
update stream which is adding new
objects new vertices and edges to the
graph so you have vertex insertions and
solutions as well as Edge insertions and
solutions and and batches
and simultaneously while the updates are
arriving you have a query stream which
is trying to run some analytics on the
graph and importantly these queries
should be running on a consistent view
of the graph so you want some guarantees
on what what kind of graph this query
can see
so it's actually a guy motivated this
and described uh an approach for solving
this problem in the fully concurrent
setting and yeah the queries here are
static algorithms
so looking at this model we're going to
call this the streaming graph processing
model and it's not really related to
graph streaming like the way um like
Andrew McGregor and folks have studied
right so this is a different model where
we're basically streaming the updates
like there's a stream of updates and
queries that are arriving and we want to
process them in very low latency
so you want to basically run the queries
on some consistent snapshot or view of
the graph and produce some responses and
you also want to apply the updates to
the graph with low latency
so for example some um
you know one
solution that we should kind of consider
and then disregard is well what if we
just you know run the queries and then
block the updates while the queries are
running we just wait until the queries
are done and then we run updates that um
you know that will fail because what if
the queries are taking a very long time
then the updates become very delayed and
new new queries that start running while
at the long running queries running will
see a very stale copy of the graph and
similarly we can't just run updates and
block until the updates are done because
there might be a very large rate of
updates
so we need to somehow run both the
updates and the queries simultaneously
so that's the goal in the setting we
want to get low latency for both updates
and queries that arrive concurrently to
the system
is the setting clear to everybody
I'm assuming here that the updates are
coming from like some source of Truth so
there's a single rider that's basically
publishing these updates I'm not
allowing I'm not going to allow
transactions to the system
just to make sure like a query a quick
query that comes in later it's okay for
it to answer a query about a more a
newer version of the graph then then a
query that was queued in earlier but
took a very long time exactly exactly so
we're going to basically um serialize
these queries at the moment they arrive
in the system they're going to grab a
snapshot of the graph and then run on
that snapshot
so the answers may not be serialized in
the right order so
um
basically the queries will get
serialized at the time they arrive in
the system and grab a snapshot of the
graph and that's the view that they're
going to get so basically you'll run the
queries in time order that they arrive
any other questions
so um also just as a you know as a
hypothetical there's some consider
people have considered well what if you
just use a single version of the graph
and run both the updates and queries
concurrently and hope for the best
um I want to briefly convince you that
this is going to cause problems let's
say you're using you're trying to detect
triangles and you're using triangles to
identify fraud or something
um then the query could be looking for a
triangle could basically search edges
and if your graph evolves in the
following way
um the query will detect a triangle even
though a triangle never actually exists
You observe this three cycle but the
three cycle never actually exists at any
point in time and if this is you know
your if your bank account gets locked
for this you're going to be pretty
annoyed right so you don't want this you
want the algorithm to actually run on
snapshots of the graph that exists
actually exist at some point in time
so the question we're looking at in our
in our work was can we actually design a
scalable and space efficient and here
space efficiencies with respect to the
best static representations of a graph
and we want the representation to be
batch Dynamic so it should support
batches of updates and Achieve low
latency in this graph streaming model
so as a starting point for this data
structure let's consider a classic data
structure which is the purely functional
balanced line research tree and we'll
see that this data structure is achieved
some of the properties but fails to
achieve space efficiency okay so
um you should just be thinking about
this as a red black and AVL your
favorite balanced binary tree structure
and the nice property about purely
functional trees is that they enable
efficient snapshots
so a snapshot in particular is just the
root of one of these trees once you're
once you have the root of the tree
because the the tree is purely
functional it means that future updates
are actually going to create new
versions of the tree so the old versions
are never actually modified and so these
snapshots are immutable
so for example if we're inserting the
element 12 into this tree we'll just
create a copy of this path and then
insert 12 where it should go and even if
we need to do rotations and things like
this there's only a constant number of
rotations you need to do and so
basically with log n
um
with a login depth path copy you can
basically insert elements in and this
also generalizes nicely to handle
batches of insertions and deletions so
for example using the Pam Library you
could you can get algorithms that have
work K log n over K plus one and and
poly logarithmic depth
how does this compare with like
persistent data structures so this is a
this is a persistent data structure for
a tree it's a persistent tree thanks
I I have to say we haven't looked at
other like kind of persistent data
structures so I think I might have got
to share a question or
workers compared to like what I spoke
about yesterday right yeah
just compared to what I spoke about
yesterday I I didn't wasn't doing a copy
of the whole past I was starting at the
node that was being updated and just
making a lot of copy locally and the two
approaches have advantages and
disadvantages that's right
yeah so we're not storing version lists
on nodes for example like the word guy
was talking about yesterday
so how do you represent a graph using a
tree let's say we have this graph here
um kind of echoing off what what Helen
talked about
um really all we have are if we have a
set data structure we can represent a
graph right so we just use our trees as
sets and we can think about storing this
graph as a nested tree of trees so
basically there's a tree of vertices
that's storing the vertices like so
that's this tree with blue notes and
each vertex has associated with it as
its value for example in an edge tree
storing all of the edges incidents of
that vertex
so for example vertex 0 is Edge tree
it's incident at one three and two it'll
have one two and three in its Edge tree
and similarly for vertex 3. is this idea
equipment we're just storing like a
nested tree of trees so the
the edges exactly the connectivity is
just in the edges represented in the
green trees every vertex is going to be
connected in this tree right so it comes
into three trees are just some data
structure storing the adjacency
information
so this Faithfully losslessly stores our
graph
and once we have
our graph represented as purely
functional nested trees in this manner
we get a graph representation that
becomes safe for concurrency so in
particular if we have a query that has
serialized itself on a snapshot of the
graph like this if there's some update
that comes later and modifies the graph
the modification basically the query is
immune to this modification it doesn't
see what happens in this modification
so the query becomes safe
um for concurrency and we can you know
even though this query is very long
running we can now start updating the
graph even while the query is running
because we're just going to point back
to old copies of the graph and we don't
actually modify them
so what are yeah Jason sorry I just go
back to my common persistency so like
you can view functional as also like
this persistent as well like are they
the same or is there like a difference
between the two concepts you know so I
think purely functional data structures
are persistent data structures right but
there are other types of persistent data
structures that use for example version
lists and there are other techniques for
achieving persistent data structures
that um are different from
path copying like the way I'm talking
about it here
so if when you insert a single ad you
need to copy a path in the H3 in a
Vertex tree what is the space usage of
like a single edge insertion
um
I guess it's it's roughly it's gonna be
like log n right but do you have like I
mean but there are like constantly they
have like uh so that would affect this
do you have like specific numbers
um no I don't have specific numbers but
yeah it's in practice it'll be something
like um you know like 10 10 to 15 pound
copies like no it's that are copied
right actually it's a good question we
should probably Benchmark this um
something we should definitely do it do
you have a question yeah
so quick question about adaptivity here
so if if this query comes in and you use
copy v0 and say okay based on this query
now I want to insert something
presumably you need to be working with a
later version V1 V2 what have you right
um
how do you actually deal with this
saying like it's safer concurrency
so sorry based on the based on what the
graph the query is seeing you're saying
you're going to insert things into the
graph data structure based on the query
um then the query that single query
should be the only thing that's doing
right so if you have basically multiple
queries generating rights you need like
a stronger kind of system where you have
multiple like transactions we're not
dealing with transactions right so maybe
it's maybe the query is the only one
doing writing but then it's safe for
concurrency right
this is the single writer assumption
yeah there's some challenges of using
just purely functional traces I've
described one is that we get very poor
cache usage we're basically storing
every Edge in the tree in a separate
tree node and that's going to mean many
many different like many cache misses
when we're accessing
um you know for example when we're
mapping over all the edges in the tree
because these edges The Edge nodes can
be stored all over memory and for
similar reasons we get very high space
overheads so for example in a tree you
typically have you know you have
pointers for your two nodes as well as
some metadata that tells you
um some balancing information so maybe
it's the size or the height if you're
using an AVL tree and so all this starts
adding up so you need between 24 to 32
bytes per node in the tree so the number
of tree nodes becomes very costly
so for example if you just took the web
data comments Gruff and stored it using
plain old trees it requires about seven
terabytes of memory but we could do this
statically using about 350 gigabytes of
memory and so this represents about a
20x overhead over just a static
representation and this is a pretty high
price to pay for a dynamic
representation
so the question is can be obtained the
same Advantage the advantages of purely
functional trees while avoiding these
disadvantages and the main idea in the
two works I'll quickly sketch here is
the the whole idea is to just put pack
more data into a single node so you kind
of keep trees but you're going to
compress them by using arrays as much as
possible so it's kind of a hybrid data
structure that's between a tree and an
array
so you might wonder why not just use a b
tree and the issue with B trees is
although they can maybe help you
compress and use arrays path copying
becomes very costly because now your the
nodes on the path that you're copying
need to be of size about B right
so our idea the first paper that we
wrote on this was a randomized data
structure and the idea is basically to
pick a hash function and subsample
elements to be heads with probability
about one over B and B is set to be
about the size of a cache line so if you
do this you maybe you'll get this set of
elements the yellow elements to be the
heads
and then you construct a tree where all
of the elements following the head in
the sorted order are associated with the
head that occurs before them
so here for example 19 and 25 are going
to be associated with this head
um this set of four elements are
associated with this head and this head
has no elements associated with it
additionally you'll have a set of
elements that don't have a head
associated with them and that's what we
call a prefix
and so the overall representation is a
pair of this prefix and this tree where
the the keys are the heads and the
values are the arrays that are
associated with the heads
now the nice property about this
representation is that the these arrays
have size about a b but B in expectation
so if you size if you basically set B to
be about the size of a cache line you're
going to be storing arrays that have a
size of about one or two cache lines
and furthermore the number of
heads that you expect if your Sub sub
sampling probability one over B is n
over B so for a tree you basically
reduce the amount of metadata you need
to store by a factor of B
so this is
um the main advantages for space
reduction
and furthermore we can further improve
the space usage by taking these arrays
which are different which are sorted and
then difference in coding them
could you have a question
so is this uh is it
why not just sizes of B and why use a
random hash function so we later we do
we like get rid of the randomness
um so we can do that using a slightly
different data structure where we
basically take the leaves of the tree
and then contract subtrees of size
between B to 2B to a single array that's
like the other data structure we yeah
and that also works
so we can we know how to do batch
updates on this um it's basically
similar to some data structure um some
algorithms that um tarjan and brown
design in the 80s
um everything good happened in the 1980s
and we're just uh
reliving the work of art that happened
in the 80s in some sense
um but we can kind of generalize those
algorithms these join-based algorithms
to also solve uniting two of these these
three data structures so how do you
handle like a batch insertion you
basically just build you can think about
it as building a tree on the batch and
then calling Union and these bounds that
you get run in pretty much the right
time for comparison-based data
structures the dependence on B is wrong
or too high in this first data structure
but we fix this in later deterministic
data structure
so overall the the the framework that we
design it's a framework for graph
streaming called Aspen
um where we basically have a purely
functional graph representation that's
using these compressed purely functional
trees there's two two versions of this
that we have now
um and on top of that you get a query
interface for queries to run static
graph algorithms as well as an update
interface for the single writer
so what's the space Improvement that we
get so compared to this 20x overhead for
plain old functional trees we get a
factor 9 reduction in space so we can
store the web data Commons hyperlink
graph in about 700 gigabytes of memory
and this represents about a 2X overhead
for dynamism in this graph streaming
model where we actually get nice um you
know purely functional snapshots
perform in practice
well I I said that the main goal was to
use use this data structure in a single
Rider multi-reader concurrent setting so
we we conducted the streaming experiment
where we wanted to understand what the
overhead for running this data structure
in the concurrent environment was so the
update stream here is basically obtained
by sampling insertions and deletions
from our graph and simultaneously we get
a stream of parallel BFS queries on
random vertices so the whole experiment
is very artificial and this is par for
the course for work in this area and we
should really try to get more realistic
data sets we should talk about that
offline
so what the question is what's the
impact of concurrent execution for us
concurrently applying insertions and
generating new versions of the graph on
the query latency an answer is that
there's no there's no difference there's
like a three percent difference in
latency so you essentially can run about
80 000 updates per second on a single
thread while you're concurrently running
BFS queries with all the remaining
threads in your system and you see no
difference in the latency
there's like a three percent impact
second question is what compared to
Prior work on bash Dynamic
representations we compared ourselves
with stinger which is an older work but
there's actually newer ones that we
should compare with
um and here we're drawing batch ads
insertions from the rmat from an rmat
generator
so we represent our graph using Aspen
and stinger
and we're asking how does the throughput
scale as a function of batch size
so we see at the lowest level we're
getting about 32x more updates per
second and up to 300X more updates per
second now if you remember Helen's talk
yesterday you know we you saw that
basically we were comparable to Terrace
and so this the throughput that we
achieve is comparable to more recent
kind of state of the art in place
Dynamic data structures like Terrace but
we're much better than um the prior
stated art at the time
I'm going to quickly skip over this part
I just want to say that what sushant was
suggesting which is basically another
deterministic approach for generating
these compressed trees goes through you
can basically take your tree and take a
weight balance treat and take the sub
trees of that tree that have size
between B and 2B and block them together
into an array and now every time you're
doing updates you kind of merge these
leaves together so you can kind of
basically do One path copy and spend
time log n over B followed by like a
single array operation on this block of
size about B and this also works and in
fact the data structure is quite nice
because it gives us a general purpose
representation of compressed sets and
Maps so we can we're actually able to
compress both the vertex tree as well as
the edge trees and this gives us about a
1.3 to 2.6 x Improvement in Space over
Aspen so we get we can basically reduce
this representation for the hyperlink
graph down even a bit more by about 1.5
x
um I'm going to wrap up now so one
question is well how does this all work
with Dynamic graph algorithms right so
let's say we want to implement the home
the Lichtenberg Thorp algorithm so what
do we need to store well a very like
kind of standard approach might be to
store the edges in the data structure
the different levels the edges in per
level and separate hash tables right and
there's also going to be some Euler tour
tree per level
so
basically when the algorithm is doing
the replacement Edge search it's going
to map over a bunch of these edges and
move them from one hash table to another
and if you think about what you probably
have going on in your system you
probably have another copy of your graph
just storing the edges somewhere else
right so you you have all these copies
of the edges and the overhead in terms
of the bytes per Edge that you're paying
can be between 50 to 80x right so 50 to
80 bytes per Edge which makes it so that
you you can't really run a dynamic
connectivity algorithm on large real
world graphs
so we have this um kind of idea for how
to integrate the storage for the HTT
algorithm which I think is a good uh
test test case algorithm to actually
Implement efficiently
and you can it turns out you can
actually like inter integrate the level
of storage into the directly into the
graph representation so I can basically
store my edges in a data structure like
a c tree and think about basically
placing barriers in like think about
basically sorting the edges in my graph
or incident to a Vertex based on their
level and then when I'm scanning over
edges in level three looking for a
replacement Edge all I'm doing when I
push them from Level 3 to level four is
changing where this barrier is so this
you know I need some extra data to store
where these boundaries between levels
are but I can get away with basically
the same storage for the graph and kind
of pack all of these
um edges
um in in different levels to be
contiguous and we should be able to use
like the C3 representation to do this
is some ongoing work that we're doing
the question really is how do you
implement the HTT algorithm space
efficiently and I'm happy to talk about
this offline
so I want to end I'm already a little
bit over I want to end by it for taking
three minutes to tell you how to do work
on bash Dynamic graph algorithms in
practice
um so for those of you who are doing
more Theory work but you're interested
in doing practical things useful
so the first suggestion is to pick
problems people and people I mean
practitioners care about
so picking problems that practitioners
are already working on uh makes it more
likely that any sort of improvements you
do in practice are going to matter to
somebody so when you build a library
maybe some computational biologists will
actually use your work and it makes it
more likely that real world data sets
are going to exist right and this is
more interesting and fun and
benchmarking with synthetic data you can
potentially just collaborate with people
right income bio or
phylogenetics like I'm working with some
phylogenetics people recently and it's
been a lot of fun
um
the second suggestion is to use highly
optimized parallel programming
Frameworks and here I'm just advertising
what we all use in our community there's
a wonderful Library called parlay lib
which came out of guy blalock's lab and
he and his students and many others have
been contributing to this library and
using it in their work so you can get
this on GitHub and the code for that
maximum contiguous subsequent sum is
shown on the right here and basically a
lot of the heavy lifting that you would
do to write this algorithm yourself in
some framework where you're programming
the parallelism manually is abstracted
Away by very efficiently implemented
Primitives so you can do things like
parallel like reduce you can create
sequences you can create sequences that
are not actually even materialized in
memory
um I think you do a lot of beautiful
things and there's a lot of examples you
can find on the parlay lib website so
it's also a good tool for education and
if you're teaching parallelograms
courses you should definitely check this
out
a fork join parallel programming
framework with a Works dealing scheduler
inside of it so you can describe
algorithms that basically do fork and
then join later so any sort of nested
parallel algorithm not to this framework
why should you use this well if we all
start using the same toolkit we can it
makes it a lot easier to share our work
and compare against each other's work
and we can start building an ecosystem
where we actually all you know bench
it's easier to Benchmark against each
other's codes and start building up
highly optimized Dynamic codes and I
also want to say that the parlated
framework is being used at Google and so
this streamlines industrial evaluation
and adoption for algorithms
you should also rent or buy a multi-core
server I just want to say if you want to
buy it's really not that much money so I
bought a 96 core server with 1.5
terabytes of memory used for about seven
thousand dollars and I can afford that
like I could buy that myself I got
reimbursed but you could buy that
yourself
um and okay the pro of renting is that
you can for example try Sapphire Rapids
or some fancy Hardware without
purchasing it which is very expensive to
purchase but the cost of renting can add
up if you do buy don't put it in your
office because it's very loud it sounds
like a airplane you know you're like
next to an airplane or something like
that this is in my office for a week and
then it got moved to a server room so
don't put it in your office
and lastly my my humble suggestion is
please write implementations that
actually run on real data sets like you
should not be testing on graphs with few
thousands of edges or millions of edges
you should really try to build
implementations at scale to billions of
edges billions of vertices and billions
of edges and the moment you take even
basic questions that we think we
understand well and try to scale them to
very large scale new problems and
interesting questions will pop up
um some ones that I'm interested in well
how do you do Dynamic trees that support
path queries and actually Implement them
um some beautiful questions about like
Edge orientation that would be fun to
solve
um and of course how do you do practical
bash Dynamic connectivity
um and yeah please evaluate on big
graphs so that's it thanks for your
attention
I'm way over so I can take questions
offline thanks slasher for the amazing
talk we have a break after so I guess
we're not we're not uh
some time for a few questions
um going back to the
yeah so going back to the static shared
memory algorithms you mentioned that the
number of processors is now small
um so it's good to optimize work over
processors plus steps
and on the other hand much of the work
on Parallel algorithms is on reducing
depth what do you think is the right way
of thinking about this
um as a theoretician and like if you
only care about asymptotics we cannot
consider the number of processors to be
constant whereas it's just reducing like
optimizing the work right that's true
right no I mean I'm not going to say
that depth doesn't matter at all right
um in low death algorithms are still
like usually practical right but for
example like mosin's paper on like DFS
trees and like linear work near linear
work and like in depth or something
right like that's a cool result and as a
community I think we should kind of be
more accepting and interested in those
kind of results
um because yeah work efficient
algorithms are
and you still have good parallelism for
that algorithm right the parallelism is
polynomial
yeah fair to assume that basically the
number of processes some N2 Epsilon or
yeah it's a guy do you have a question
yeah just again
yeah on this topic yeah just make this a
discussion yeah I think what's more
important to look at is the the work
over the depth which is the parallelism
and like you say you would probably want
that to be like into the Epsilon so into
the one half or something like that but
you don't so if you have an algorithm
that's n cubed work you could could even
put up within to the three halves uh
depth and that would still give you
plenty of parallelism
and so if you look at it more that you
want the parallelism to be high rather
than the depth to be low then it might
be a better way to look at it
so back to the practicality of the
shared memory uh static shared memory
algorithms at the beginning of the talk
saying there were two kind of key
ingredients here there was a compression
scheme and there's also these classic
pram algorithms adapted to this uh new
representation is there any sense in
just kind of figuring out which which of
these is doing most of the heavy lifting
of the numerical improvements you could
run everything we did without the
compression and it would still be fast
like for the very largest graphs
compression seems to make maybe like a
1.5 or 2x difference but you're just
pushing less data through memory into
your lashes so that's what helps
um but yeah that's really not the
compression it's more like the parallels
yes
the compression is what lets you do it
with less memory which
so compression mostly saves on Cache
yeah they still had to pay some CPU
Cycles to decompress but for a very
large graph the compression is a nice
picture it's also bandwidth right
exactly for bandwidth reasons
thanks
[Applause]
we'll have a quick break and we'll be
back at 3 15